this is a production of cornell
university
so today we're fortunate enough to have
dr kyle wickings uh
one of our entomologists here at cornell
uh to talk about
annual bluegrass weevils spring
emergence
scouting uh for all those in the chat
box there's a link
uh to a new resource that kyle helped
develop with our new york state golf
bmp project uh so i'm sure we'll be
talking about that today but
um let's get it started frank i'll give
it up to you for some uh opening remarks
and then
we'll get kyle's thoughts on things okay
thanks carl
can you hear me okay yep good for now
okay so uh here we are week two
uh i'm gonna try to keep us distracted
for a little while uh and just start off
by saying if you got these kinds of
projects that
uh the bethpage folks have had been
working on through the
time uh and you're able to work and it's
safe to work
these are not such bad things to take up
right now because as i'm going to tell
you
we're not going anywhere fast at least
as the weather indicates and so just
again
happy to have you all with us uh thanks
to kyle
and of course to carl for being the the
sort of rod that stirs the
coffee as we say um and and really
bringing us all together so we can uh
get some information how to deal with
this in our in our professional lives
okay first let me just say as a member
of cornell university uh really happy
and honored to be part of an institution
where we can continue to do this
provides us the opportunities to do this
take care of yourself they say stay at
home if it's possible please do that
we hope the economic worries don't trump
your health and everything else sorry
for the pun there
uh but uh that we hope uh that you're
keeping yourself safe
we're really fortunate now within a week
a major golfing organizations have come
out
with really good guidance on these on
these issues now i'm going to take issue
with some of the things they say but
overall man
this is what real leadership looks like
big kudos to
anna miller at the usga uh red evans and
all the folks at gcsa pulling this off
even setting the lead
uh for the playing end of this the pga
of america is linking to the gcsa site
now
there's already reports uh across the
country
of operations uh where someone's got a
positive
and so i would immediately encourage you
to check out this uh
section of the gcsa website to keep you
informed about how to deal with this
this is a serious situation and if you
don't plan for it
some guys okay i gotta get hours so you
got
five days ten hours a week and then the
mechanic works at night
right you gotta have split crews uh if
somebody gets a positive there's a whole
lot of things that can happen
here's a really good piece of
information for where you can start with
understanding this this is really really
great now
where are they playing golf well they're
playing golf in all but 12 states
including alaska right now
uh we in new york state uh there are
orders but
that you could play uh but some local
restrictions it's
the patchwork nature of the united
states that concerns me the most about
this
um i feel it's a sort of a long-term
effort to decentralize a fair amount of
things and this is what happens when you
need some centralization so again big
kudos to the usga and gcsa for taking
the leadership on this
but this does wreak havoc particularly
for those of you on borders of places
you're running a business on the border
of these operations you're close
somebody else is open
economic as well as health worry so
thankfully again there's guidance on
this the pga of america and the
european sources are providing safe ways
to play i'm sure you
as golf course superintendents as
assistants it's critical
if you're on the site you're the
facility leader there you are one of the
few essential people you notice that's
shutting the clubhouse
they're shutting the pro shops you may
be considered one of the only people who
can go
in and do work this is what's happening
in the uk in ireland
where only the green keeper can go to
work with a piece of paper saying here's
what they're going to do and here's why
they're going to do it
and here's why it's essential so my
advice while we still
are in the waiting of a lot of this in
new york state
that we prepare fully all right this was
a nice little question that got asked uh
the other day by the usga
and uh not long after that minimal
maintenance state
standards came out and this is where
lots of questions remain
this is where if i was a golf course
superintendent or anybody
in course management that's responsible
for making the decisions of caring for
the property
i would be sure to review this now i can
take issue with a lot of these things
you know you read some of these things
like irrigation equipment maintenance
that was done
you know maybe in the winter time
irrigation
you know lots of interesting things here
the rna
actually put out a little bit more
detailed one that i like
uh there's a little bit more here that's
like irrigating to keep the turf alive
right irrigated to keep not not to
necessarily provide playing conditions
right
so where are we in keeping the turf
alive relative the weather
right because we're going to get to
whether you're playing or not in a
minute
but right now it seems like it's
encroaching
in a pittsburgh area and as you move to
the south
so right now soil temperatures still
remain fairly cool
for much of the northeast you're barely
barely creeping
into the 50s in long island and the new
york metropolitan areas
upper 40s low 50s
the air temperature continues to be
below normal and you see the same
wave of weather uh that just came
through we're
at or below normal in a lot of places
now what is forecasting well you know
the good place to look for data and i've
been stressing use
data in this situation the good place to
look for data
is our forecast website we have all this
information there and this is indicating
at least
from a northeast climate center that rd
guytano our shortcut weather expert
is telling us we're going to accumulate
very little growing degree days for the
next coming week
right so until april 6 we're really
planning on not a big
move in the weather now when we think
about weather when we think about data
we go back to some of these data things
that may ah
growth potential i just watch and look
and look at the bucket i don't weigh
clippings i don't think
well now it's a good time to start
thinking about huh
my air temperature looks like it's upper
40s
that's indicating i'm at 15 growth
potential so that's indicating even if i
throw tons and it's not going anywhere
right the plants aren't growing we're
not going anywhere
right we have time in many cases
now here's where it gets tricky
if you're at a place where the nutball
250 rounds a day
you know 15 000 carts on the golf course
and it's all of a sudden between the
hash marks at
the lambeau field between the 20s and
between the hash marks and you got a
you know a race truck race course going
out out there
man you know protecting the asset means
keeping up with it
if you can if you can but if you're in a
place where play is scaling back
and you're not getting much play or
you're getting some but it's no
different
you don't see any wear marks in the
pinch points
you don't see anything happening yet
even though the plants really aren't
growing
you're in a good position so you should
be mod moderating modulating
the decisions you're making for on your
golf course based on traffic and growth
right that that's the governing body
right now
and again at our forecast website one of
the things that you know maybe twitching
to want to do
if you didn't do it in the fall or if
you're an mba or embark person
you can go to our forecast website type
in your zip code
and we have a lot of predictive models
we've had them there for a decade
now we certainly want to update this
more and more but what i like about this
is we're telling you
pretty much till the 7th of april
right in upstate in much of northern new
york except for the metro area
you've got time for you got time for
proxy
right embark uh is still coming a lot of
you still use embark
but these kinds of models are good to
look at so you can deem
when i really need to go in and do
something
monitor these tools to keep up with what
you got to do if you can't get to work
because your quarantine
right here's a good example this is
again for
uh the northeast region and you see down
the side here is the predictive model so
you get this customized for you big
kudos to rd guy cap
all right i'm wrapping up and i want to
wrap up by first saying okay where are
we early season disease-wise
right well we saw some early season
anthracnos
on some golf courses early and there was
a twitch to want to go spray
i was more of the opinion and generally
are of the opinion and
in promoting herd immunity uh you're
getting anthracnose lingering over from
last year
you're getting some early season
anthracnose now uh i've seen many cases
that does not develop the full season
anthroconos why don't you let those
plants go we got more and more guys
letting plants go
with the weevils to bring in other
plants be they power or bent
but something that can tolerate this
problem this management that you're
doing
now is the time to be looking at that
microdoping conditions are up there it's
unlikely you're going to get death
high value areas you know you obviously
want to look at
your fungicide options pythium root rot
ugg right you already
got pity of root rot we're soaked the
soils are saturated
i'm not of the opinion we should be
running out there
and i'm feeling like i'm horton hears a
who again everything i see in the
mainstream industry is saying hey go
go go i understand that to some level
but if some of these problems are
structural why not start that
conversation about look
at this is what i'm dealing with every
year even when you're not out there
right i still think we have plenty of
time until root pathogen drenches are
needed and then
so thank you uh i don't know carl if you
want to do some questions here or pivot
right to kyle
i want to make sure kyle also talks and
promotes this wonderful resource
because uh people in the lawn of
landscape we told them a little bit
about this
you may see some grubs out there might
be some good time
to um uh to uh identify those things so
uh
carl i'll i'll pass it back to you
brother i'll stop sharing here
all right um so no questions no
questions so far on kind of that growing
season update
um so i think uh what we can do is kyle
we can
get your thoughts you can share your
screen and give us a little more insight
on on the abw
issue um i noticed some names down here
on the participant list long island
others from from different parts of the
country who may not
uh have much experience with abw so um
i'll head back to you sure that sounds
good thanks frank and carl for having me
and uh yeah i think just since you
flashed that grub key up it's worth
mentioning that
um just looking at soil temperatures
here i think most of what i've been
seeing a little um earlier than that
still so
where i am in the finger lakes we've
still got 40 degree soil temperatures so
they're quite low and uh but that really
hasn't stopped
things like white grubs and crane flies
coming back up there they're active
right
now so we've got them all in the root
zone we've got birds and mammals going
after them right now as well
so um so they're there and they're
feeding
but again you know what we talk about
and what you'll see
in this key for management
recommendations for grubs this is you
know this is a window to really
the only thing you need to do right now
is mark where those areas are and just
keep them in mind
they're good areas to check out if you
did a fall application uh curative
application for white grubs to see
what type of winter success you had or
winter mortality but that's about it
so no no real um need to worry about
and panic about white grubs at this
point so just keeping an eye on how
things look is the way to go but they're
back
for sure uh crane flies are another
story some folks try to do for things
like the european crane fly
spring curative applications we're still
a bit early for that things are still
too cold
the numbers aren't as high as they'll
get and
so we're still early for that as well at
least a month out for that sort of thing
but if you if you're looking out there
i'm sure you're seeing some vertebrate
damage and i don't know carl if we had
that question throw go up there in the
poll
but um that's something that at least
area i'm seeing quite a lot of quite a
lot of vertebrate damage including at my
own house
flickers and skunks and everything else
all over the place just tearing stuff up
so but again temperatures are low for
soils so that that's something i was
surprised to see
um those predictions having us in the
mid to high 40s to even 50s
i'm not not actually seeing that in both
the southern tier or
in the upper part of the finger lakes
area so still still quite cool
um moving on a bit to talk about
annual bluegrass weevil um this this
is one that we've been starting to scout
for already because of some of the
changes at cornell
we've been slow to get our degree day
monitors up and running
but um but we have been doing vacuum
sampling to scout for a new bluegrass
weevil
so um carl you made a good point that
not everybody's necessarily got any
bluegrass people on their radar or is
managing them or is used to scouting for
them so
frank had suggested i put some slides
together to just show sort of the
general overview of the life cycle and
kind of where we're at
so i can do that now
just give me a second here to share my
screen
and i and i always think it's a good
refresher kyle i mean i think now that
we're in
uncertain times with what we're going to
be allowed to do
understanding the way these little guys
are you know because we don't have the
same flexibility if you're down to two
guys
you can't think around i'll just pray
you do have an alleviation that you
don't have to worry about golfers maybe
as much some do but but i think by
understanding some of the basics of
these things
you might think differently about how
you'd strategize at a time
that that actually you can justify as
minimal right as minimum
yeah yeah that's that's a good point and
just uh carl just want to let you know
that looks like you as the host have
your
screen share for participants disabled
so i'm not able to share mine for some
reason but
we can certainly do this without the
screen share it's just a bunch of goofy
cartoons i put together
no uh let's see i'm gonna allow you to
i'm gonna make you a host and uh
okay now i got to show you this goofy uh
slide should i put together there we go
nice
all right you guys got the presenter
view or the audience view of that
looks good here that looks like
audiences okay great
so in typical uh dr wicking's fashion i
um
just kind of illustrate things and the
general life cycle
so for those who aren't familiar with
this um annual bluegrass we
over winters in our natural areas on
courses this can be anything from tree
lines to shrub lines to taller grass
that just has a lot of dust and leaflet
left on it
anywhere you get that buffering climate
and uh and protective
uh microclimate so typically
and where we are in november through
march this is where the adults are
spending their winter
so we're really trying to um pick up on
the movement of the adults out of these
areas on our courses so
um you know typically as spring
progresses you'll get
march through may this progression
towards the shorter moan turf this is
fairways
uh t's green scholars all that and we're
really trying to tap into this point
where
are the adults along that that um that
spectrum of
that that space and movement and that's
really critical of we're looking at
doing a delta side applications
and um a lot of folks are really focused
on adult sides and and focusing on
managing adults
and really knowing where the adults are
is pretty critical to doing that
so um there was a blog post on the
weeble track
blog by ben mcgraw he's been getting a
number of calls from people asking can i
do something now
you know we're short staffed we're
trying to find things preventatively
that we can do
to save us later can we do management
against any bluegrass people adults now
and just like the story with crane flies
and grubs it's it's just too early
so our scouting essentially is putting
us
here for adult movement we're seeing
them outside of the native areas
are the natural areas they're they're
active and they are moving but we're
really not seeing
um that progression and that stacking up
um
towards the edge of the roughs near the
fairway is in greens and stuff
that we're looking for so activity is
still way way back here
if you're really focused on phenological
indicators those are lagging as well
we're seeing some activity but even
things like forsythia
down in the third tier of new york are
just starting to break buds and
and get some foliage on it so we're not
really seeing um
anything near the start of activity even
with those uh indicators
around here so i've seen some blog posts
down state showing that they've got
uh things like forsythia developing much
much quicker
but that it's a bit disconnected with
the movement of adult weevils right now
so in a nutshell holding off for now now
this isn't a great time to try and
encourage people to take on new
practices like scouting
but if you've got the ability and you're
thinking of trying to do anything
the main thing that you could do right
now is try to get a sense for where on
your course
the the wheels are so if you know you've
got some problem areas from past years
doing some scouting in those areas to
see where along this trajectory you've
got
the weevils is a really great way to
give you some peace of mind and a heads
up
on what to think about moving forward
for
if you are going to do an adult aside
application so um
i can show uh the the screenshot of our
bmp to show the web
address for that in a bit but just as a
general sense for how we do our scouting
uh this say for example is an area where
we have had a historical problem
what we'll do is vacuum sampling in
bands going from the natural area or
native area or whatever that
transitional edge where we think they're
overwintering
out to the playing surface so we'll take
vacuum passes in these areas ours are
about
uh 20 feet apart 20 to 30 feet long
and will basically try to pick up on
that wave where the adult weevils are
and that's your best
indication of when um when you should be
thinking about doing a delta
side applications when you've got adults
all kind of stack up along this edge
out here um so
but again we're essentially what right
back here in central new york we're
nowhere near that point so
way too early um best thing you can do
if you've got the ability to do it is
get out there and do a little bit of
scouting
so if you don't have a vacuum sampler
using soapy flushes in areas like this
is a really great way to do that as well
so it's a much
much cheaper way to go about it if you
don't have the resources right now to
tackle it
so if anybody's interested in doing that
um it looks like i got my
screen there we go so we do have a
resource online right now
it's uh called the decision diagnosis
decision making for any bluegrass
weevils this has been put out by the
golf course bnp project and um it's
available as sort of an e-book online
right now
we've got instructions in here for doing
soapy flushes vacuum
sampling as well as using linear pitfall
traps so it covers everything from
degree days to timing and decision
making as well
so yeah this is a tough time to put new
practices into your your management
scheme that you haven't done in the past
but
um any ability to get out there and get
a sense for where weevils are at now
will buy you some time and um give you a
good heads up for later on if you are
going to make a management decision
so carl i don't know if you had any poll
questions kind of responses come back
for that adult aside
poll but i would be curious to know
we're starting to see a shift of guys
looking at maybe doing larvicides
instead of adulticides now
um if they really can't get a crew out
to do much management right now
but um yeah i'd just be curious to see
what the responses are there
yeah so we got a 50 50 uh half half
did apply a delta side half didn't and
then we just ran the um
uh poll question for timing uh so it
looks like
uh about 60 of people um
scout about 40 percent of people use
phenological indicators before cynthia's
uh 32 percent use growing degree days um
and then 18 use other so um and that was
a question where they could select
multiple answers if they wanted to yeah
yeah that's great to hear that some
that's scouting people are looking to
scout there we go i'm seeing the the
results up there now so
yep yep yeah scouting i'd be curious to
see what kind of scouting folks are
doing i know
um some people are really married to
soapy flushes i think you can cover so
much ground with vacuum sampling if
folks can
get on board with that so we try to give
as much detail as we can in that ebook
on how to start doing vacuum sampling
and we have a link to our web page too
for how to make a cheap vacuum basket to
put in your sampler
to use for that because that's the one
thing you're not going to have when you
buy the vacuum sampler so
yeah as far as phenological indicators
go uh yeah again in central new york
we're seeing really
very little activity we're seeing
daffodils push uh
but yeah as far as uh for cynthia goes
we
tend to think of full bloom forsythia
when adults become active
the majority of adults become active and
then half green half gold forsythia
being when
adults are in peak at peak activity out
towards the playing surface edges
so we've got a ways to go for leaning on
phenological indicators for that and
that that's coinciding with our scouting
data too
as far as degree days go i know some
people about 32 percent mention they use
growing degree days
uh we're typically looking at about
anywhere from 120 to 150 for
peak adult activity and we're we're
still in double digits in most places
that i've seen in new york state
so again even if you're leaning just on
growing degree days the signs should be
telling you it's too early for that as
well
um so so we do have one question from
ted uh it was a good question actually
frank and i were talking about this
um back and forth uh he's asking if
uh would you recommend doing a glory lap
he calls it around natives or natural
areas to stop the adults from entering
the shortcut turf
um i know you did some work a while back
with the overwintering uh
research and different methods of
control there you want to talk about
that
yeah so we did look at some um
management practices within sort of
graph
grassy natural areas and basically it
was looking at mowing
and what uh the use of herbicides and
then whether or not we left the dead
residue and clippings there or we
removed them
and essentially none of the practices
that we looked at in those grassy areas
improved our control of annual bluegrass
weevil but some of the practices we
used made it worse or for how well they
overwintered so when we left residues in
those natural areas
after mowing them or treating with
herbicide we got much better winter
success for the annual bluegrass weevil
so
a significant increase in the the
overwintering success of the adult
weevils
so but that being said back to the point
of
the trying to confine them to those
areas to prevent them from coming out
uh that's a that's a good uh question
and uh
but one challenge we have is that a lot
of danny bluegrass weevils are
overwintering in
in other areas so they're overwintering
in roughs
there were a bunch of warm-ups that we
had this winter where i was out
vacuuming just for curiosity's sake and
finding weevils active
outside of the natural areas kind of
scattered so it's not to say they're
everywhere all the time
but it does seem like this particular
winter we had kind of activation of
weevils in different spots around the
courses to get them out of those
those natural areas or maybe they
overwintered outside of it to begin with
so
i wouldn't look at it as though it would
give you a really good confinement
strategy by any means so
but that's a great question um yeah so a
good question there from ted and then we
got another one in from dave
uh any thoughts on using wetting agents
or mineral oil
instead or with a traditional delta side
app so i think the mineral oil
probably referring to civitas and i know
you've got
some answers there probably yeah so ben
mcgraw had done some work on that and
i'm i'm not real clear on on the
benefits it's going to bring
there's been some some evidence that it
kind of has a smothering effect on it
um but again you know i'd say right now
um
any thoughts of any type of combination
treatments like that
are still way way out um i i think that
the best thing we can think of in a
situation like this is
if we're gonna invest any time at all um
try to do it in scouting to get yourself
a better heads up on what's to come
kyle i was looking at the growing degree
days on the forecast uh
website uh carl i'm going to take the
screen again here for a second
uh just to draw everybody can you see
the uh growing degree day model there
kyle yeah
so so this is uh growing degree day
accumulation as of a couple of days ago
and your 120 to 140 is uh
looking like it's just uh creeping into
delaware this week
i'm sure there's better data than this
uh we'll update this i would imagine any
day
i think it's today or tomorrow uh this
will get updated
uh and then i also draw your attention
to the
we also have the forecast here
um so my first question is before i get
to the forecast
we use march 15th is that the baseline
you guys use in scouting
we've been using march 1st for ours that
doesn't mean that's when we started our
monitor but yeah
march 1st march 1st is the start for us
okay so so let's look at the forecast
and we're only expected throughout the
entire region over the next
week to get single digit accumulations
yeah so this is what you mean by early
based on the weather even in the metro
areas
uh that might be listening where the
pressure is intense
yeah the last post that i had seen had
degreed that the highest
degree day accumulation in that area i
think was still
uh like between 50 and 60 so far
so yeah we're we're just at about half
of what we're looking to accumulate
before we see
peak adults so yeah that people should
be taking that as a really good sign
that
nothing needs to happen yet that's right
and and hello
if your target is the adult it's not
that the adults are overwintering
they have to come out of the canopy if
you're even if you're using things like
civitas or any
uh pyrethroid there has to be that
contact
and it just makes sense that if you're
gonna get a good shot at it here
and keep in mind too right let's keep in
mind by all
estimates by you know that whatever news
people you
subscribe to we're looking into june for
this right
think about the traffic you're in stress
you're not gonna have
hopefully not gonna have from the
traffic and mowing and all the things
you have to normally do
so put that in your calculus as well as
the fact that the
weather's saying early the target's
telling us early the scientists are
telling efficacy as early
you know let's not wait for another shoe
to drop before we start sort of hey
here's what we're going to do
uh with regard to this um kyle i got
another question about scouting
um so for people who maybe haven't done
it before i know we talk a lot about
asynchronous populations in abw and on
one area of the course
you might see adults in another area you
might not
how many areas i guess roughly or have
you seen that there's a wild amount of
variation in this but how many areas on
a golf course should you be scouting for
whether you're doing the soapy flushes
or the pitfall traps
that's a great question i mean normally
i i tell folks scout as much as you
possibly can
initially to get a sense for where
things are at and then narrow it down
from there but you got to do something
pretty intensive up front
that's a pretty tough recommendation to
be making right now obviously so
i would say if all you can do is get out
a little bit
uh go to those areas you've had some
historic damage from and you tend to
have chronic problems so that's a really
good place to start
and if you can sneak any other areas in
there if you have some likely areas that
have
good looking overwintering habitat i
know that's kind of hard to define but
areas with a lot of accumulated leaf
litter
sort of that good buffering environment
that's a good those are good sites to
hit up as well
one the reason we typically argue for
vacuum sampling is because
the the amount of time you lose going
and checking areas out is much lower
with those you're not sinking a ton of
time into the scouting
it's just the initial investment in
getting the vacuum sampler and setting
the thing up
so uh typically when i go and scout a
new area
i can make those tasks between a native
area
and and a fairway for example in about
an hour and i've got a pretty good sense
for what's going on
so um so that's where a method like that
you're not you're not feeling the the
pain of sinking too much time and just
one one thing for one insect you know it
can be pretty quick
and i think the feeling with soapy
flushes unless maybe i'm just bad at
them but
i think that those tend to feel like
you're investing a lot more time when
you
do a method like that so in a typical
season i'd say as much as you possibly
can on your course if you don't have a
good handle on it yet but if you have a
pretty decent sense
go back and hit up those areas that you
know tend to have damage because that's
at least going to tell you on
in general where things are on your
course
and again you know a lot of times kyle
i've heard you tell me when and and i
think even dan peck and um
his graduate student didi at the day and
and then masa
after that didn't they find sometimes
populations were just as high in the
center of the fairway but there was no
damage the damage has always been
really associated where there's some
other
uh persistent stress that the grass is
struggling from there there's a fair
amount of
populations and feeding stands can
handle
when there's not that stress so again
uh that also has to be part of the
calculus now
i always worry because i've chatted with
ben in the past and he said yeah
i still like the adulticide i i don't
like the larva side strategy only what
about the guys
that have done that in the past with
success and now we're considering wow
this is beautiful i don't have to worry
about this at all and
i can start my salt things later uh what
about that uh
cohort and the concern that by not doing
an adulticide
uh it allows our population to get uh
enormous
yeah i think there's some some that's a
really great topic and there's some good
and bad to that strategy you know that
the good is obviously we're getting
around the challenges of
how difficult it is to make a decision
for like properly timing adulticides
and uh especially in places where we've
got pyrethroid resistance
that known to happen um and i have seen
some courses switch to larvicides only
those tend to be courses where they
don't have
raging populations all over but they've
had pretty good success with it now they
are also courses where they're scouting
regularly
for both adults and larvae so that
that's something that
i think you absolutely need to do if
you're going to try and switch to a
strategy like that
but the risk with it is certainly that
if you don't have that timed perfectly
well
um having not done the adult aside
earlier puts all your eggs in that
larvicide basket and that which is
always a
challenge with such a cryptic and small
insect so
right and and i guess what i would say
is uh
intimately knowing where people are
doing this strategy because of
resistance
yeah um then it becomes well what is my
adult aside choice now that i think
dursbay and i have to be honest kyle i
don't know there's been yeah or nay but
i know even our long island uh folks uh
now have uh a celebrant so can you chat
for a minute about what having this new
tool does or doesn't do to their their
decision making now
yeah it certainly gives us uh another
option on long island for
doing a preventative application for
larvae so that's something that in the
past if you were going to do that you
had
neonics or nothing for preventative so
if you
were struggling with managing adults and
then wanted to switch to managing larvae
you had to focus on a curative
application much much later on long
island when larvae are emerging from the
stems
so that's even riskier because it's like
the last chance
once those larvae are out of the stem
and in the soil but having the diamides
in the mix
there now gives another tool in the box
for
trying to insert some kind of a
preventative effort that's not just a
neonic
for trying to get systemic uptake and
then control once you've got larvae
hatched in the stems
so so that that is another option that's
that's there which which is certainly
helpful especially if we think about
the potential to lose products like um
some of our organophosphates that are
also used in rotation for adulticides so
we've got we're kind of
losing one and maybe gaining another so
okay well lots of lots of thinking ahead
for this i i
think this is something we're going to
be revisiting pretty regularly
as guys are starting to plan so kyle it
sounds like the message from you for
today
is uh we got time use this time now
to uh look around and understand how the
populations are moving and i keep
thinking
that you know we have to be a lot more
precise
uh than we've had to be in the past
because of
our lack of workforce uh and and
and you know and and having to only be
able to get in to do what is essential
and you'd say that something endemic
like this on long island or down in the
metro area for sure for sure in hot
spots throughout the northeast
that that you know having that precision
is going to be
better this year and that's only going
to come from looking around
yeah absolutely obviously again i
totally know it's a tough thing to add
something else to the list but if you
are looking to do something that that's
what you should be doing right now so
hopefully and what you said about
precision you're totally right i think
in some cases that
freaks some people out and say well if i
can't do this in this incredibly precise
way then it's not going to be useful for
me to try it
um but so i do think that there's some
simple ways that scouting can be started
on courses
and you can can get a decent sense for
what's going on without feeling like
you're taking on this new massive task
that
has too many moving parts so that's what
we're hoping that bmp document can help
clarify for some folks
yeah so um frank i don't have any more
questions i'm sure once we get into the
thick of the growing season we'll
probably have more and
you know kyle we'll probably invite you
back on uh when the time is uh
right there but um thanks again for
today um
stopping by and chatting for a little
bit uh thanks to everyone again for
attending
uh we've gotten a lot of great feedback
from these um so again as always we'll
post this on youtube as a recording
um and uh we'll see all those who are
interested in tomorrow's our sports turf
talk we'll have uh bill croiser on
actually to talk about
growth and pgrs uh for those who don't
get their turf that that's
a higher focus on higher cut turf right
because the sports guys and the grounds
guys
are interested in what happens if i'm
mowing inch and a half
two inches and and golf guys haven't
started thinking about uh
how they're going to manage their rough
yet from that and it's a very different
uh
it's a very different discussion when
your grass isn't actively growing so
again big thanks to kyle thanks carl
kyle thanks for joining us
we're going to have you back as long as
it's convenient um
so so it's pretty convenient for
everybody when they're sitting around
the house but you got a youngster around
so that uh
adds to the interest so uh good luck to
all of you
out there working uh work safely uh
and and look for those resources to make
sure you can work safely keep you and
your
uh crew safe that's that's got to be job
one and
and these are really just designed to
help you make decisions about the
a lower priority at this time i don't
want to say a non-priority but a lower
priority at this time keep yourself safe
and and do what you can to minimize with
being out there
thanks a lot all right thanks everybody
we'll see you next week
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu